un magnifique mâle chibane ou de retour
au studio après une longue période
d'absence
il profitera régulièrement de la
moquette pour se mettre sur le dos et
réclamé des petits câlins et des bisous
pendant de nombreuses minutes mais il
sent très mauvais de la laine les amis
qu'est ce qu'il a de plus drôle que la
chaîne de squeeze tout mais qu'est ce
qu'il ya de plus drôle que des feuilles
de panoramas et oui cette fameuse option
disponible en 2018 sur tous les
téléphones du monde elle fait des
ravages mais qu'elle ouvre des portes
qui mènent aux enfers pour ceux qui
savent pas ou qui pratiquent très peu le
panorama c'est vrai que généralement on
utilise à pour faire une photo d'un
paysage mais c'est très déconseillé de
faire un panorama quand tu prends une
photo de quelqu'un qui pose devant
quelque chose pourquoi parce que si la
personne bouge l'algorithme va vraiment
créer un [ __ ] de morceau on va checker
ensemble ce que ça peut créer vous allez
voir c'est un délire pourquoi je parle
comme un présentateur télé je ne sais
pas de mount engine
comment c'est possible mec non ça va pas
du tout fait ça on dirait un montage
sony vidya soir gare et les mâles détour
est carrément assis ok il était un gros
plan hockey si il était juste vraiment
très gros plans devant la caméra et ça
ok c'est bon ces attaques comme titan in
real life
ah voilà ça c'est le cas classique des
chèques de panoramas ce classique one on
l'appelle ça te fait une traînée
dégueulasse derrière la tête n'a en plus
à lui à déformer l'oeil et tout ou alors
son vrai visage
tuez-moi horrible this man and google
earth hour puisque comme il balaye
gouverneur c'est pareil ça peut créer
des problèmes 2 au mec c'est vous ce à
relier le hot ce mec au bas de quelqu'un
d'autre c'est très critique j'adore ah
oui
l'échec des panoramas souvent ça
rallonge où ça raccourci quelqu'un ou un
objet est là par exemple sarah course et
un bus et ça a créé le premier [ __ ] de
bus de room c'est vraiment minibus mec
quoi y'a même tu veux le faire en
photoshop y arrive pas sa survie à un
monde dans lequel tout n'est que fail de
panoramas rejoint quand tu prends le bus
ce but cela qui va noter ce délire de 0
à 10 on est là on est là yassa à ok lui
son téléphone il a une feature ce pour
faire un selphy grand-angle et en fait
c'est isabelle technologique le panorama
oaxaca mexique lippi mon pote m'a alors
par contre je suis désolé vieux mais ta
copine a vraiment fait cette tête le
panorama n'a pas pu créer une expression
de visage sa copine avant de faire cette
tête en mode chez bell fait cette
systématiquement tulle a juste pris en
flagrant délit le panorama n'a rien fait
avec ça crée des choses crippen est
vraiment regarder ça vous avez un enfant
qui tirent la tête un autre enfant qui
lui a volé son son jouet c'est horrible
j'essaie de prendre un panorama de la
tour eiffel et savent donner un truc
génial mes mecs cergy bien pourquoi
réussir ses panoramas alors que quand tu
les foires ça donne un truc créatif trop
cool alors la mecque j'ai su recréer un
[ __ ] on n'a pas les mêmes téléphone
[Musique]
c'est vraiment ce réveil à sur les
animaux mec si de gros comme ils bougent
d'animaux il va jamais posé il va bouger
donc si tu fais un panorama ça va
forcément raté au nom même et en plus
j'ai déjà vu cette photo elle aggrave
fait le tour cette photo j'ai déjà vu
c'est ce truc là oui ça c'est du
panorama réussi et veille
en plus le fond tout est parfait quoi
c'est vraiment le truc à bouger à ces
cris pis ça devient une sorte de conte
kangoo chien de mer dans the violent
mais pourquoi ça fait pas ça toi tu
pourrais tu as juste un trou du cul qui
marche
bon en fait on est déjà
assez dur ça quand même à ça ça pouvait
presque démonétisé ma vidéo nan sans
déconner ça se trouve mec c'est pas beau
de rabat c'est juste normal et ça
devrait être pas empêcher de penser ça
mais est-ce qu'un prêtre stephen hawking
avait pas du tout un handicap mais c'est
les gens qui le prenait en photo qui le
prenaient un panorama et et sa foire et
à ya plus de coûts baissent et pour les
grands coups lasky complexe la sncf
c'est pour toi voilà j'ai pas dire ce
qui je parle de seb linverse d'un grand
coup ça donne ça m'aide c'est beaucoup
moins cool quand même est plus proche de
taizé celle en plus donc si tu sues tu
le sens immédiatement que plus fort
j'essaie de monter morale un pote en
plus une vidéo voilà bon alors ou la non
non mais ça fait raison là vous avez
sûrement entendu parler de ça il ya une
communauté de gens
à terre il plane mecs qui étaient à
l'extrémité de la planète et qui a vu la
cascade kaubach de la planète parce
qu'on met elle éclater
[ __ ] [ __ ] mais c'est dingue comme
c'est bien fait je te jure que le
photoshop et y arrive pas ça c'est
dingue ça crée vraiment des trucs
crédible c'est ça qui fait flipper en
fait je trouve c'est que ça crée des
trucs crédible tu passes le week end à
londres en coupe tranquille et tout a
juste pris un panneau tu vois le busca
cette gueule sur ta photo tu bloques tu
remet tout en question
ah c'est un baiser au riz j'avais déjà
patron et faire des enfants mais alors
la mecque
le mec est devenu de lover which should
un terrifiant on dirait haslem durban
les carpes ou trop manger c'est fou le
retour du chien de pâtes les mecs en
fait les dinosaures ce pareil mecque le
t-rex c'est un panorama cas foire et non
mais soyons d'accord c'est vraiment si
elle désirait ce qui regarde la vidéo je
suis désolé mais à un moment il faut
l'admettre
ces photos de dieu improvisé ied salle
croyais à j'aurais trop d'avoir une de
moi je suis jaloux personne ne parle
dans le dos de ce mac
[Musique]
la légende est parfait si personne ne
surveille mieux ses arrières que lui ça
n'existe pas les amis les panoramas fait
c'est terminé ils arrivent à l'heure
limite il y en a il y en a plus en fait
tout simplement oh c'est un flat bonus à
yémanja tesserete bonus qui tombe
connaissez-vous la pari d'owlient mec je
bégaye sur des mots pt et le mot pari
d'owlient il passe nickel quoi alors que
boulanger j'ai du mal à le dire à côté
ça incroyable notre cerveau à nous les
humains il aime pas l'inconnu il
structure en permanence son
environnement et il veut donner du sens
là où il y en a pas forcément et
l'appareil de lycées ce phénomène en
fait on va associer un stimulus flou est
inconnue à quelque chose de claire et
identifiable
sauf que contrairement aux illusions
d'optique qui marche de la même manière
pour tout le monde la pareille d'olite
ont vécu son expérience sa culture et
ses influences et ce que tu vois test de
rorschach
ça y est je suis grillé humilié et sur
haut parleur
j'allais dire que c'est sûr ça qu'est
basé le fameux test de elle le dit très
bien bref on a très souvent tendance à
voir des visages là où il n'y a pas
forcément de visages on a tendance à
repérer des yeux et une bouche alors que
ça n'a rien à voir ce qu'on voit et
apparemment ça viendrait de notre
capacité à identifier très facilement un
visage donc une présence en fait c'est
un instinct combat et je trouve ça hyper
intéressant commençons avec avec cette
photo d'un feu dont la fumée semble
affiche
j'ai un visage le nez ici la bouche ici
les yeux ici voilà vous voyez ce genre
d'exemple alors qu'en fait c'est
carrément jus de la fumée a pas de
visages ou de présence dans cette fumée
cet arbre dans pokémon qui ressemble à
un mec musclé énervé qui contractent ces
deux-là pari d'owlient voilà cette boîte
a connu des jours meilleurs
la dore comment notre cerveau nous joue
des tours c'est fou on a presque de la
peine pour cette voie de [ __ ] faut pas
que je montre sa natsu mec c'est quoi
ces dépôts chocolat vous dirai
clairement aucun chinois ont fermé deux
enfants à temps j'aimerais lui montrer
non il va dès que je monte une vidéo de
chiens ils courront pas qu'un chien je
suis débile faut que jade est gaga
non mais y en a des incroyables le mec
se met de la crème hydratante sur les
mains ça crée un petit chat mignon on
n'a pas la même manière de se mettre de
la crème très clairement quand on vend
très content de voir une bière son vote
la situation est folle c'est drôle oh là
là le bouchon de réservoir d'essence qui
fait l'ombre de batman c'est tellement
emblématique ben hadhbane que des
convois deux petits trucs comme ça hop
c'est batman stephen hawking arrêter de
faire des rêves à stephen hawking après
on va croire je me moque des handicapés
et ma chaîne youtube va fermer tout
simplement mais ce qui est triste c'est
que c'est vrai ça me fait penser à
stephen hawking parce que le tout que
j'ai vu le plus penché finalement
c'était la tête de stephen hawking à
cause de son handicap donc c'est vrai
que du coup quand je vois un truc est
proche et la même manière ça me fait
penser à lui c'est fou j'ai mis deux
jours à le voir on dirait une grand-mère
qui met du rouge à lèvres et comment on
réussit à voir aussi c'est précisément
un truc quoi et ce avec les gros yeux ça
fait penser aux grosses lunettes de
grand mère le petit break iv du rouge à
lèvres sur la bouche en eau la [ __ ]
mais même la nature si mes gros c'est
normal ça on va arrêter les bêtises à la
fameuse multiprise c'est vrai c'est
l'exemple de la pallée rli de lady bas
ça y est je vais bien je vois un moment
je pense que la première fois ou même si
tu sais pas encore ce que c était
victime de parler de lui c'est en
regardant une prise c'est le truc number
ones deux trous un plus gros trou
le tout sans parler de sexe évidemment
vous pré crise c'est vrai on dirai
clairement dessin à tel point que
peut-être que le robot a détecté que ses
dessins et que la vidéo va être
démonétisé c'est possible clément on le
laisse au portage juste pour voir je
veux gagner d'oslo démonétisé
je revendique et qu'un mec aille à ce
moment-là il fasse bon effectivement
c'est pas des saints c'est des raisins
rockets alors la place et bien joué en
forme de guitare par dessus des lignes
électriques donc on dirait que la ligne
sont les cordes de la guitare
c'est magnifique ils savent ils savent
qu'ils sont trop vieux cas des
interrupteurs bien mieux que maintenant
ils sont fabriqués les interrupteurs
plus beau plus ergonomique ils le savent
ils vont dégager
ouais j'ai mis du temps à le voir mec
mais là c'est creepy as fuck voyou pas
voyez ou paula atchia il est reconnu
mais colas à genève et sur twitter
le truc des deux avions qui tape une
barre c'est pareil c'est la pari
d'owlient vous voyez vous étiez victime
de ça sans même savoir ce que c'était
comme phénomène
n'êtes vous pas content avec cette vidéo
de savoir mettre un mot sur votre
ressenti ouais je sais trouver une
utilité à regarder mes vidéos mais non
ouah carnet incroyable ça il envoie de
l'eau sur un éléphant et en envoyant de
l'eau ça forme une tête d'éléphant c'est
incroyable à mecs j'adore et qui s'écrit
pis je suis sûr qu'il ya très longtemps
on savait pas mettre un mot sur ce
phénomène par exemple et du coup on
croyait vraiment par exemple que l'arbre
qui avait une forme du visage c'était
quelqu'un qui était réincarné en arbre
et s'est sûrement que la science a
grandement évolué on peut mettre un mot
sur des phénomènes et mieux les
comprendre c'est intéressant je trouve
voilà j'étais le petit mon premier degré
de la vidéo et bien les amis c'est la
fin de cette vidéo j'espère qu'elle vous
a plu sur les sadristes et kdc paris
comme d'habitude ben voilà deux trade en
a fait cadeau ça régale dont l'un des
deux
quand même basé sur un phénomène du
cerveau qui est quand même incroyable
quoi c'est fou je deviens parano mais je
regarde tout autour de moi dans l'espoir
de voir des visages
j'ai envie je devient accro à sa ces
foules sur twitter hésitez pas à
m'envoyer si vous voyez votre panorama
ou si vous voyez un truc qui vous fait
penser à un visage envoyé le mois sur
twitter sont intéressants aux basics
cousue voilà je sais que quand je dis ça
après je reçois des tweets en rapport et
ça me fait kiffer je vous dit attendre
une prochaine vidéo portez vous bien je
finis la vidéo comme je l ai commencé en
faisant des câlins à mon chien
je t'aime lattes mais tu t'en fous avec
le moc roquette qui est intéressant
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]